we are now approaching our destination
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
please we have to get on that boat
abuela
what the hell i'm gonna do with baseball
cards do you have any idea what these
are worth
let us do oh yeah marco
always making new friends danny you're
late where's alejo
he gave up his ticket for his family
[ __ ] alex was an orphan
alejo's not going anywhere anymore
come on let them on
good man get out of boxing
[Music]
don't worry about it chamaco here that's
all i've got
this isn't right bunny we should be
fighting up running to the young keys
alejo gave you a [ __ ] gift lyda we
survive
same as the orphanage same as the
academy
please no no this is
[Music]
before he was el presidente
me papa love to fish we would go out on
a boat
just like this and we would catch the
fish
and then release them he would say
it's not always about your stomach miho
it's about the challenge
except when he caught a big fat
juicy marlin he was too proud
to let that fish go
i've caught a very big fish today
haven't i diego
no way
i have caught you mijo now it's time to
bring you home
i don't want this anymore papa we have
no choice
let them go they can work make viviro
truth
or lies truth
they could be good workers
they could help rebuild paradise
but if you wanted them to live
you would have never set foot on his
[ __ ] boat
13 years old and diego has
such compassion for his people
these fish
we will catch a release
i used to feel so much peace
staring into the heavens until a piece
of it fell
[Music]
and the nightmare began
[Music]
we thought it could be contained
but it evolved so
we did too one of our own is m.i.a
i need an extraction team now
if there's a way to stop them
you will find it
but i know
you will find me
[Music]
first
okay plan nomad secure
let's go
we are already out of the nests incoming
area
stand back
[Music]
clear let's move out
[Music]
clock's ticking
i found her
hold on
[Music]
check for the exit
and apex
not so fast
[Music]
cover me
hey you all throwing me a party
yeah dude budging me stole the fireworks
team it's ash we're not done yet vip
down
tell your mother and sister to
you are alive
that is all that matters
peek-a-boo [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am i
[Music]
i too am a king who isn't afraid to
slaughter to get what he wants
[Applause]
is this a test a dream
an opportunity then i will not waste it
[Music]
you are beyond salvation
did i ever tell you the definition of
insanity
you